these hacker groups we all have these
little clicks and we had this one called
Sesame Street hackers and there was this
kid Darkness he was 15 and he broke into
a satellite and he instead of deleting
the logs he accidentally deleted
everything on completely screwed up and
the administrator of that machine came
into our IRC chat uh and he was like
you're all they're after you and he had
red defaced our defacement but he said
they know all about you and you know you
could see the IP address that he logged
in from and it was an as one and he just
knew way too much information about what
was going on and he was like you know
you should probably contact them before
they contact you so he gave me the
number of uh Sheila Brock I think was
her name this NASA has an investigative
arm called o oig the office of the
Inspector General and I just basically
said I heard you're looking for
me